si on décide de faire du vie que c'est
quand même pour s'éclater transgresser
se faire plaisir
[Musique]
moi je suis arrivé avec un discours très
simple je fais du x et j'aime ça et
apparemment c'est quelque chose
d'obscène de dire que on a du plaisir à
exercer son métier à utiliser son corps
à en tirer du plaisir
puis en ce qui me concerne j'ai eu la
chance mais aussi la volonté d'utiliser
le x comme un moyen de m'émanciper de me
découvrir je suis quelqu'un de plutôt
introverti et puis tout de réserver ses
min ran à la base c'est quand même une
étudiante qui qui était plutôt plus un
petit rat de bibliothèque que la pom-pom
girls des lyrides de sa fac
aujourd'hui je suis riche de ça mais ce
n'est pas pour autant que je dis fait du
porno puisque fait du porno c'est la
seule manière de vous éclater de vous
découvrir pas du tout l'industrie a
beaucoup changé quand j'ai commencé il y
avait un côté très transgressif qui
donnait beaucoup de saveurs elle
s'éteint à ce métier petit à petit ça
c'est vrai que ça a évolué avec internet
avec une industrialisation qui a
entraîné des biens des tournages plus
formaté et moi et moi humains l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai quitté ce
milieu c'est qu'au bout d'un moment je
me suis plus reconnu là dedans et qui
avait un côté tellement industrialisés
que finalement on en perd l'essence même
de la sexualité qui elle échange c c'est
con mais c'est quand même la base
j'ai trouvé beaucoup plus de confort et
de meilleures conditions de travail en
bossant aux états unis le public aussi
est différent et les plus respectueux
quand on croise des fans dans la rue ils
vont nous saluer de manière chaleureuse
c'est vrai qu'en france c'est en ce sens
que je sais pas il ya une forme
d'hypocrisie ce qu'elle est due à un
mélange d'héritage judéo-chrétien d'un
tabou vis-à-vis de l'argent et d'un
tabou vis-à-vis du sexe alors que aux
états unis malgré leur côté hyper
puritains mine de rien ils ont beaucoup
de respect de reconnaissance pour les
gens qui réussissent qui font de
l'argent et puis qui se construisent
tout seul
[Musique]
moi je m'en fout en fait je m'en fous
qu'on fasse du porno féministe d'extrême
droite d'extrême gauche spéciale pour
pour les asiatiques pour les blancs ou
enfin en fait peu importe la
pornographie c'est quoi c'est de montrer
des images qui qui participent à une
stimulation qui qui sont censés apporter
du plaisir
rien de plus c'est aussi simple que ça
mais pour n'importe qui qui a envie de
se reconvertir c'est difficile quel que
soit le milieu professionnel
donc oui c'est difficile mais en fait ça
l'est pour tout le monde te conseil que
je pourrais donner aux actrices qui
veulent arrêter c'est n'écoutez pas le
bruit
concentrez-vous sur vous parce que la
solution c'est vous en fait on est
toutes des guerrières on est tous des
guerriers on a tous une force énorme en
nous mais on le sait pas forcément